with a lineup ranging from timeless
genre staples like halloween to modern
classics that include mandy and the
whaling it's not exactly a challenge to
find a winner among shutters unhinged
offerings
the bigger problem is knowing where to
start given the stigma that's generally
accompanied the vampire genre since a
certain sparkle-skinned
seed of knight gained pop culture infamy
we'll go ahead and give you a free pass
for having likely missed michael
o'shea's relentlessly bleak the
transfiguration
o'shea's genre redefining debut follows
a desperately lonely young new yorker
with a seriously misguided affection for
vampire fiction
gritty ponderous and altogether
mystifying the transfiguration is at
once
daring wildly insightful examination of
inner city alienation
a torturous exploration of
post-traumatic stress
and an obsessive exploration of a
fantasy life taken
far past the edge of sanity for the
record the transfiguration is also a
gruesome bloody exploration of urban
decay
that's wholly unafraid to dwell in
scorched shadows and filthy back alleys
pitch perfect performances from newcomer
eric ruffin and up and comer chloe
levine help
ground this moody profoundly unsettling
tale
in a heightened state of reality that
often feels a little too real for
comfort
there are horror movies that indulge in
the fleeting pleasures of jump scares
and bloodlust
and then there are movies that seek to
expose you to things that will unnerve
you in ways you didn't think possible
the sorts of things that stay burned
into your brain for months and years
after you've seen them
haggadzuza is 110 of the latter school
if you've yet to experience lucas
feigefeld's gothic folk nightmare about
an isolated woman struggling to maintain
her sanity and raise her infant daughter
in the wilds of 15th century europe
now's the time to dive in just know that
the film isn't tailored to horror fans
who get their kicks from cheap scares
and buckets of fake blood
truth be told there's hardly an ounce of
fake blood to be seen in hagatzuza's 102
minute run
time but what it lacks in gore-fuelled
mayhem it more than makes up for an
ominous energy and gothic imagery
feigelfeld uses a heavy dose of both to
lure you into a trance-like state before
bringing the hammer down with a shocking
finale
that's certain to turn the stomach of
even the most hardcore horror fan
consider yourself warned anna biller's
pseudo horror spoof the love witch is
the very definition of a breakthrough
film
though it's admittedly not the sort of
classic horror shtick some would expect
in a genre breakout
set in the modern day the love witch
tells the tale of a beautiful young
witch named elaine who is determined to
use her spells
magic and callous gender-centric
fantasies to make a man
fall in love with her the problem is her
spells and magic work
and they tend to leave a love addled
dead man in their wake
when the bodies start piling up locals
start to take notice of elaine's
bewitching ways
and the young sorceress's life begins to
spin out of control
biller takes a bracingly original
approach to this deceptively simple
witch's tale
fitting elaine's sixties-esque style and
persona starkly against the love witch's
modern day setup the result is a
dizzying often hilarious
frequently unnerving film that finds
biller telling a bold little anti-horror
tale
with some refreshingly insightful views
on gender roles
holiday horror has been a tradition for
years with filmmakers
studios and streaming services using the
concept to rain bloody terror over
every holiday from thanksgiving to april
fool's day
but back in 1974 a full four years
before halloween helped make holiday
horror legit
that was not the case so it's no
surprise that not many people really
knew what to do with bob clark's
menacing holiday slasher piece
black christmas upon release 45 years
later people still don't quite seem to
know what to make of clark's wicked
little holiday nightmare
and okay that may be because clark's
name is typically associated with the
holiday film he made a decade
after black christmas a yuletide charmer
about a boy who really
really wants santa to leave him a
carbine action red rider bb gun under
the tree
yes the guy who directed black christmas
also directed the iconic family-friendly
holiday fable a christmas story
though we'd argue that black christmas
is the better movie isn't santa naughty
oh it's also widely regarded as one of
the first
full-on slasher flicks one that finds a
bevy of sorority girls who are being
terrorized by a madman over christmas
break
from that now classic slasher setup
clark and screenwriter
roy moore craft bleak breathless
socially conscious drama
overflowing with the sort of shocks and
genre staples that have been copied over
and over in slasher movies
only black christmas is so much smarter
if the past few
years have taught us anything it's that
the so-called hollywood dream factory is
an absolute nightmare for aspire and
young actresses
still thousands of would-be starlets
flock to tensile town
every year in hopes of becoming the next
big thing most of them will fail
miserably
and those who make it may be forced to
sacrifice parts of themselves they
cannot get back
dreams require sacrifice
and so do we released in the fall of
2014
kevin kolsch and dennis widmeyer's
harrowing hollywood drama
starry eyes is a film painfully aware of
those facts
as such it now plays as a near prophetic
piece of horror fiction that
even in its unbridled brutalistic
insanity somehow doesn't feel like it's
all that far off the mark on the surface
of course
starry eyes really could not be more
realistic as it follows the talented
young sarah who
on the verge of finally landing her big
break has the proverbial
rug pulled by a sleazy producer with
ulterior motives
turns out those motives are far more
devious than anyone might have expected
a fact that sarah learns the hard way
when she eventually succumbs to his
advances
what follows is a ruthless fever dream
that's part body horror nightmare
part of cult drama and part vicious
hollywood satire
all of which likely make starry eyes
sound a bit nutty
believe us when we say it is and in all
the best ways
if repulsion style psychodramas are your
cup of tea
robert altman's images is a legit
must-see released to little fanfare in
1972
images was the middle film in altman's
unofficial gothic trilogy
sandwiched between two deeply simpatico
female-centric character studies
that cold day in the park and altman's
overlooked masterwork
three women like those films images puts
a disturbed woman's center stage
and surrounds her with altman's
signature style unlike its sister films
images uses style and setup to cast an
unflinching sense of anxiety over the
action
fleshing out the dark impulses awakening
within a tragically fractured psyche
as for the story simply tell you that it
plays out like a schizophrenic
doppelganger nightmare with the woman in
question losing her grip on reality
and finding men from her past and
present blurring in and out of seemingly
dual realities
if you're anything like us your life was
never quite the same after experiencing
the visceral
relentlessly brutal freak show that is
hooper's the texas chainsaw massacre
shot with virtually no budget on gritty
16 millimeter
featuring no-name actors and possessed
of a near-suffocating sense of
hyper-reality
hooper somehow created a horror classic
with his twisted tale of cannibalistic
hillbillies out the snack on an
unwitting group of youngsters there are
some things in this film you just can't
unsee
as for the things you simply cannot see
well if you've already experienced the
texas chainsaw massacre then you hardly
need us to tell you about them
if you haven't we wouldn't dream of
spoiling the grisly horrors that await
you within the movie's
sweaty white-knuckled 83 minutes
over the years there have been a handful
of legendary actor and director pairings
in the world of cinema
one of the more unsung pairings is that
of jeff nichols and michael shannon
to date shannon has featured prominently
in all five of nichols features
if you want to see the duo at their
absolute best look no further than their
chilling apocalyptic psychodrama take
shelter part rule family drama and part
doom-filled psychological thriller
take shelter follows a farmer plagued by
horrific visions of a coming cataclysm
fearful of what lies ahead the man's
hard-wired paranoia leads him to build
an elaborate shelter in his backyard
a course of action that threatens to
tear his family apart before the end of
days camp
featuring career best work from shannon
and a star-making turn from jessica
chastain
take shelter finds nichols playing in
genre tropes with the precision of a
horror master building the madness to
fever pitch that will leave your heart
in your throat and your jaw on the floor
you should know up front that the first
30 minutes of most beautiful island will
feel a lot more like a deeply personal
indie drama than a full-blooded horror
film
stick with it because as the action
moves along this inspired by true events
tale of a doomed american dreamer morphs
into a neo-noir
nightmare that will leave you shaken to
your core written and directed with
visceral intensity by first-timer anna
asensio were also stars
most beautiful island follows the
travails of the troubled undocumented
luciana who
in desperate need of cash takes a
mysterious job that pays a large sum of
money
it seems too good to be true and it is
ascencio wisely makes you wait to see
what the job is
instead using her film to depict the
day-to-day nightmare that is immigrant
life in america
we find out about that job in the film's
final 20 minutes
and we can say with all confidence that
you'll never see it coming
and that you'll spend the pulse-pounding
final moments of most beautiful island
on the verge of a fear-induced nervous
breakdown sounds like fun
few horror sub-genres have cast quite as
long a shadow as that of xiaolo horror
a stylized slasher-centric genre that's
given us horror fare like
dario argento's suspiria and sergio
martino's all the colors of the dark
while shutter rightfully sports one of
the more impressive slates of giallo
flicks
we'd urge you to forgo revisiting those
until you've seen the giallo entry most
commonly credited with birthing the
genre
that flick is mario bava's stylish
visually arresting murder mystery
blood and black lace set largely within
the confines of a posh italian fashion
house
this crafty blood-soaked thriller takes
a relatively formulaic
whodunit narrative about a killer office
models
and spins it into a savage takedown of
the world of high fashion
along the way bava employs all the
trappings we've come to regard as giallo
staples expressive photography
bold use of colors and lighting and a
masked psychotic killer with an affinity
for leather gloves
it almost unwittingly transcribes the
formula for giallo horror as we know it
in doing so bava also made a first-rate
slasher flick that influenced every
genre gem that came after
over the last eight years
writer-director mickey keating has
quietly crafted one of the more
intriguing genre resumes in the movie
best
2015 alone zakirin released two feature
films
the first was a flawed but fascinating
family drama sci-fi confection by the
name of pot
the second was a brooding black and
white beauty about a young woman's
spiraling descent into murderous madness
simply titled darling that film is as
close as keating has come to a legit
horror masterpiece in his still young
career
and it features a positively
electrifying performance from
up-and-coming star
lauren ashley carter as for the
darling's plot
it first presents itself as a simple
haunted house chiller following carter's
peggy as she signs up to play caretaker
to a
gothic style brownstone which naturally
supports all manner of creepy
backstories about hauntings and occult
activities
there's even a locked room that peggy is
forbidden from entering from that
admittedly cliched setup
keating spends a sinister surprisingly
gory and wonderfully complex
psychological thriller
in the vein of repulsion and the shining
while darling doesn't quite reach the
iconic
level of those films when a horror flick
looks this good
and is so lovingly assembled it hardly
needs to
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one